[Music]
so much stimulus coming to kids iPhone
internet social media remember I have to
go look at where's kids not a care in
the world maybe running the car shotgun
that was like the biggest problem in my
life shotgun
yeah I never see kids doing that anymore
the only time a kid yells it out now is
in a classroom
oh school shootings what a bummer huh
ah the great American Pastime yeah I
like how they're blaming the video games
video games cause violence come on video
games don't cause violence video games
cause carpal tunnel and vaginal dryness
[Music]
I know a lot of guys they play eight
hours of video games a day and their
girlfriends are like violent slap my ass
choke me I'm dying here
translate to real life I grew up playing
Monopoly with my friends none of them
now own property
to be fair some did go directly to jail
[Music]
thank you